mais pour autant l'accord issu du Sénat
est un accord qui permet d'avoir cette
loi et donc j'ai plutôt tendance à vous
dire que si jamais ça pouvait passer euh
bah ce serait bien pour la France voilà
donc c'est un message que vous lancez au
députés LR ou C votez la version du
Sénat parce qu'ils sont pas tous sur
cette ligne a par ex il y en a très peu
qui sont sur cette ligne donc ça
m'inquiète un peu mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous dise je pense
que c'est l'intérêt de la France voilà
vous craignez que le texte ressort de la
commission des lois avec à nouveau euh
la suppression de l'article qui supprime
la me donc un rétablissement de la me et
un article 3 qui soit beaucoup plus
souple écoutez c'est c'est tout ce qu'on
veut pas quoi en fait voilà c'est-à-dire
que l'idée c'est que moi je pense que
laame non mais l'aide médicale détail il
faut il faut il faut une bonne fois pour
toutes tirer des conséquences de tous
ces abus c'est considérable c'est plus
d'un milliard d'euros l'aide médicale
d'État n'a aucun sens autant ça a du
sens de traiter les urgences autant de
de de de faire que des des étrangères
situations irrégulières est une totale
gratuité des soins alors que ceux qui
sont en situation régulière comme nos
compatriotes payent des franchises c'est
délirant délirant donc là c'est une
partie de la majorité que vous pointez
du doigt parce que c'est cette partie de
la majorité qui dit je nous ne voterons
pas le texte si on ne rétablit pas la me
et si on rétablit ça fait
malheureusement des années et des années
que c'est comme ça que nous ne sommes
pas capables d'avoir une Assemblée
nationale en phase avec à la fois le bon
sens et les attentes du pays voilà mais
c'est que la majorité ou c'est ou c'est
aussi chez vous chez les répou deux les
deux vous m'avez demandé la majorité je
la majorité mais je vous dis les deux
bien sûr mais c'est le le je pense que
nos amis députés LR doivent intégrer
quand même que cette loi elle est
nécessaire on peut pas toute la journée
dire que ça ne va pas qu'il faut une
politique ferme en matière d'immigration
et de l'autre quand on a des mesures qui
aident à régler un certain nombre de
problèmes ne pas la voter ça n'a aucun
sens
aucun